you know it's hollywood you go through
relationships you go through breakups
you hear it all the time every actor
goes through it are you mostly friends
like for instance bella thorne i don't
know if you want to talk about that but
do you are you still like
what's the word uh cordial cordial for
sure you are yeah probably more than
cordial because when you go through a
relationship you go through
it depends obviously how it ends and why
it ends um
but you know i think with with bella and
i have just always
just
it was always important to me that she
grew up
to
live out her truth
um and so we come from
very opposite
uh
family dynamics um and so she
unfortunately lost her dad when she was
i think nine
um and so it was really important to me
that she felt loved and supported
whether or not she was in a relationship
with me or out of a relationship with me
um and so after the relationship it was
uh yeah important to me that i was i
always i said it to her so just so you
know like i'm
i'm i'm here for you as a as a as a
friend i always will be and i always
will be um
so if someone came up to her and said
hey how was it dating greg sulkin
you think she you does your gut say what
did your gut say you think she'd say
i'd she wouldn't i there aren't many
reasons why she would say it was bad
you know like
she i mean nothing's perfect yeah no no
things end most things end yeah she she
would say
yeah i probably love greg it's probably
it's probably what i think you hope she
would say that yeah yeah i hope she
would say it but i think she probably
probably would and how much does
michelle like you talking about her
bringing up her name bella invites us to
her birthday parties every year come on
so michelle and this is
like a fairy tale
life here yeah but i think it was
important it's nice we both all three of
us actually created that dynamic because
it requires a lot of like maturity
maturity yeah you know
me making me explaining to michelle that
like
bella's a person
that
i will always
be there for if she ever needed
something michelle was like extremely
mature and understood that and respected
that and then on on on um
you know on all angles just like i wish
her the best she wishes me the best she
loves michelle i really respect ben who
bella's engaged to now
um
so yeah just sort of
you know
hey can't ask for better there's nothing
worse than an ex hating you yeah there's
just no need there's just no need
there's no need for it especially if no
one's done anything wrong you know if it
was just a simple simple like hey we're
just growing just to work out we're just
like we're not we're not compatible yeah
you